hi everyone and welcome thank you for
coming we're here today to talk about
communicating climate change science
this is the sixth and final event for
the year of the research without borders
series sponsored by the scholarly
communication program at Columbia and
also by the Earth Institute we have
three panelists and plus our moderator
so I'll introduce Robin Bell the
moderator she's a senior research
scientist at the lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory and she specializes in the
stability of ice sheets and how I sheets
are changing and she'll introduce our
panelists thank you very much for coming
when I should also say we're videotaping
we'll have a Q&A session after everyone
speaks then if you have a question
please step up to the mic in the middle
of the audience so we can get your
question on audio thank you bye okay
thank you everybody for coming today I'm
Robin Bell I work at the Institute if
you don't know that's about 15 miles up
the river not sing sing but up on a
cliff it's where a lot of the climate
and earth science research at Columbia
happens and why this is a fascinating
topic to have here is this is exactly
the topic that we talked about at lunch
a lot we're a community of about 400
people studying the earth and we sit
down at the cafeteria what we talk about
is how do we communicate science and the
science of our changing planet to our
peers and to the public and to
policymakers so that's why this is a
wonderful discussion to be having in
this forum today so this structure is
going to be we're going to hear from
each of our three panelists they're
going to talk for about 20 minutes we
aren't going to take questions
immediately afterwards so we're going to
hear everything we have to say from
climate modelers to visualization to
data that what people think about
climate and then we're going to have
questions in a dialogue so that's the
plan and we're going to start first with
Gavin Schmidt who is a climate muddler
NASA yes which is just down the street
he also is one of the editors of real
climate that you may have been too he
got his degrees in mathematics and
really is interested in how to model the
changing climate so first we're gonna
hear from Gavin okay thank you very much
for coming and no so I'm just going to
talk and if I repeat myself just just
kind of growl at me with something and
I'll shut up i'm also trying to try and
be quite brief because i think in forms
like this we can gain a lot more by
actually responding to questions that
people have rather than just sitting up
here and pontificating about what we
think pontificating a bad word this week
um let me talk a little bit about
climate science I'm not going to talk
about the science um you know you can go
and read my papers you can ask me
offline you can check out my blog real
climate if you want to do that you can
buy my book which is all about science
but I'm going to talk about the
environment in which climate science is
being done um you would have had to have
been living under a rock the last six
months if you were not aware of the fact
that climate science has become
intensely politicized this is the kind
of thing that happens whenever people
perceive that there is a threat to
either that analytical view their
religious view their ethical view their
moral stance from something that's
coming out of the scientific community
this is not unique to climate science
it's something that occurs with
evolutionary biology it's something that
occurs with fishery science it's
something that occurs really whenever
science is seemed to impinge upon
something that people are much more
closely tied to than the scientific
method so people are much more wedded to
their political opinion about how
markets work for instance or their view
of their right to burn fossil
so whenever and however much they want
than they are to you know integrity in
paleo climate studies this has led to a
very clear scientist a shin of the
politics that's not my word that comes
from daniel sarah wits and it describes
the phenomena by which you're going to
turn on fox news and you're going to
hear a lawyer and a politician arguing
about 15th century tree rings now
neither is people know anything about
15th century tree rings and so but
that's just a cover for their desire to
have an argument about really their
values and their values are all usually
political or ethical but kind of catch
it in the light in in in the language of
science in order both to try and
overwhelm their opponent who knows as
little about science as they do but also
in order to give their arguments of
veneer of scientific respectability
despite what's happened over the six
months scientists are far far more
trusted in the general public and then
our journalists than our politicians
than our lawyers and so if you're a
lawyer or a journalist or a politician
it's much better to sound like a
scientist than it is to stand like a
journalist a lawyer or politician
the the consequence of these events or
or of this this environment is that the
media doesn't generally see the whole
picture they generally see the science
and they look at the science the stuff
that's going on in the peer-reviewed
literature the stuff that's in the IPCC
report or Missy CSP reports and they
pass it for things that they think are
of interest in the public debate now the
public debate is completely divorced
from the scientific debate so the
scientific debate you know we have whole
conferences talking about exactly how to
reconstruct climate in the medieval
period we have whole conferences on the
interactions of aerosols and clouds and
the micro physics that goes on those
much those are the things that people in
a scientific community are debating the
public debate is what to do about
emissions what to do about climate
policy what to do about energy policy
those are very different things ah but
the science is only looked at in the
public sphere to the extent that it
projects onto this public debate now the
media's idea about what the scientific
debate is completely determined by the
public debate and not by the science and
so you end up with stories making news
or events making news not on their
intrinsic scientific merit but on to
what extent they project onto this
public debate that's a very distorted
view of what goes on in the science one
of the other elements that is
problematic in the media environment is
the fact that the media reports on news
and that's not a problem that's just who
they are they report news things like
well we've known that carbon dioxide is
a greenhouse gas for over a hundred
years now well that's not news right
because it's a hundred years old and so
things that everybody knows the vast
amount of
tacit knowledge that all of the
scientific community holds none of that
is ever news okay so none of that ever
gets reported by the media instead we
have a focus on the studies that seem to
project on sins probably debate all the
things that come out in nature or
science every week are the one or two
papers that get press attention there
are our red distills to you know a lead
paragraph and a headline that generally
completely distorts what it is that has
been found in that paper or why that
paper was ever in nature or science in
the first place what's missing is the
context why is that paper important um
there's no room for that because by the
time you've explained what a greenhouse
gases you know you're already at the
limits of your words one of the
interesting contrasts that I like to
point out to people is how much more
information there is in a sports column
than there is in a science column go to
any newspaper and you find the story
about science and you'd flip to the back
of the paper and you look at a story
about sports the sports column doesn't
bother to tell you what game they're
playing it doesn't tell you who these
teams are where the split where this is
going on or what the rules are or
anything they just say Joe of this team
did this this list and you know it's
completely in principle for somebody who
has no idea what they're talking about
in a science column they feel they have
to explain everything and so the
information content for sports readers
is much much higher than the information
content for science we do so when you're
reading the media when you're when
you're observing this is just a lay
person who knows there's something
interesting going on who knows that this
is the complex situation you're
intensely frustrated pretty much on a
continual basis you know that it's more
complicated than you're being told you
don't know where to go for more
information if somebody points you to
the technical literature quite frankly
that's impenetrable to anybody who
hasn't studied this for a long time the
focus in the media is almost all wrong
the focus is say ninety percent on these
very cutting
studies which quite often were wrong or
not replicated in the end or on things
that project on to what they perceive to
be the public debate and so you get
ninety percent of the coverage on that
and only ten percent on the basic
background knowledge there is really
informing our advice the policymakers
and to everybody else that says well you
know what we think that emissions should
be reduced if you think of if think of
science like a building think of planets
and it's like a building it has
foundations that stretch back a hundred
years there are multiple stories the
whole superstructure is is all there and
in place and the stuff that the media is
paying attention to is people arguing
about whether it's a blue brick or a
yellow brick right at the top or what
color wallpaper we should put in the
executive bathroom on the top floor
those are interesting i guess the
interior decorators and for you know
experts in in Bricker ii but they're not
the building they're not the whole thing
and when you step back away from their
car than we knew shy of the scientific
debate all you see is that big building
and that's what people should be talking
about and yet that's the thing that
doesn't get discussed at all now over
the last few months there's been a bit
of a you could call it a perfect media
storm the release of the stolen emails
from the uea server the failure and
copenhagen to to come to any kind of
meaningful agreement and the fact that
it was snowy in in washington DC you
laugh but i'm pretty sure that issue did
a correlation between how people felt
about global warming with the the the
last three months of climate in in DC
you'd find it pretty hard a pretty high
correlation it was snowing in DC but it
turns out you know that january-february
march are the warmest months on record
this year is very likely to be the
warmest year on record globally um but
again
nobody was paying attention to that so
what went on you have these three kind
of you know elements that were all kind
of feeding a particular narrative and
because the accusations that were
running around after those emails were
released released stolen by when my
emails were included in those so feel
free to go and check out everything I've
been saying over the last 13 years even
in private on the news media didn't know
where to go right the people that they'd
normally thought old as credible were
the people being accused of all sorts of
malfeasance and scientific misconduct so
they couldn't go to them um the fact is
that there aren't huge numbers of
credible scientists who disagree with
the consensus on this and so they went
to the only place they could go which
were the fringe elements the people
who've been going around for years
saying Oh climate change is a hoax and
we'll involvement some giant conspiracy
and everything that we do is design to
to force some kind of new communist
socialist vegetarian utopia on everybody
else um so what that did is it opened
our what's called the the described
interesting concept called the overton
window which is the the window or the
barriers to which are what it's
permissible to talk about in public so
if you think back over the health care
debate nobody really serious was able to
talk about socialized medicine like they
have in Europe or Canada or it or
anywhere else are because that's off the
table here right in Europe a system like
we have here is also off the table and
so discussions about healthcare in
Europe and in the u.s. don't have any
overlap at all right because the window
of permit abul opinions in the mainstay
Media is just very much more constrained
on one side in Europe than it is here
now those barriers can switch and
shipped and what happened in the last
three months is that the is that the
window for permissible opinions about
climate science shifted all the way to
the nutters now I don't use that in the
word lightly um though I was quoted
saying that in the New York Times the
other week and I got a whole slew of
irate messages how dare you call me
cambia not oh and I had no idea who that
person was so obviously it wasn't clear
that I caught him another but there are
there are nutters out there there are
people who are absolutely convinced that
every word that I'm telling you today
every word that I've ever written in any
paper is a lie and a deliberate
falsification okay it's very hard to
talk to these people so you might
imagine a dialogue with somebody who
thinks that everything you say is
dishonest is rather different but these
people were given free rein in the media
their points are were treated seriously
by mainstream news journalists not not
necessarily by the environmental beat
reporters who have a a longer
relationship with the community and to
know who the players are and they know
who's credible will do is not credible
but in New York Times for instance you
know quoted know people who have
absolutely no credibility what's your
opinion of climate science and and go
like why are they asking these people
because they don't have anybody else to
turn to so one of the things well so
it's okay so I mean they did that I
think the other speakers are going to
tell us what it is that we need to be
doing about this let me leave you with a
couple of thoughts that have arisen out
of the last
few months one of the things to be aware
of is that the things that we worry
about a lot what we talked about over
lunch in the non cafeteria for instance
these are not the preoccupations of the
majority of the population despite
everything that went on with the
Climategate affair most people if you go
outside of a very small group of people
who are tuned into this kind of stuff
most of it went completely over the
heads of most people science as a whole
is not going to be damaged by these
things the window for what's permissible
in discussions of climate science is
slowly closing back to what it was
before that but that's not to say that
we've done a good job with communicating
climate change or the science we've done
a terrible job it's basically because
it's not our job that's a big problem
but if you if you look at how deeply
people will understand the concepts that
we're dealing with here the fact that
carbon dioxide accumulates in the
atmosphere and progressively makes a
larger and larger problem the facts that
the ozone hole is not necessarily the
same thing as global warming even when
people agree that something should be
done their reasoning for why something
should be done is very very poor and
it's a kind of veneer it's a very if you
try and pro people's level of knowledge
it's it's very thin and this predates
anything to do with with the last the
last six months our ability or our
capability of explaining to people why
science is trustworthy why the
scientific method works why the process
that we go through as individuals in
this competitive environment and that
technical literature wine that has any
credibility that's where we fail and I
don't think that that's a particularly
difficult thing to get across to people
anybody who's watched a version an
episode of CSI knows okay they they know
that you can get DNA analysis in 10
seconds um but but but more deeply they
know what it is to try and find a
balance of evidence argument in a
complex situation where you have only
imperfect knowledge about what's going
on and if somebody can understand the
threads within an episode of CSI they
can understand what it is that
scientists are doing respect to climate
change um so I'm just going to leave you
with that thought and then these people
are going to tell me that I have no idea
what I'm talking about so 2 to the next
people thank you
okay thank you Gavin for your
perspective on the last six months and
how we as scientists do or don't
communicate science very well next we're
going to hear from Ned Gardner who got
his PhD in landscape ecology and then
went on to work for the American Museum
of Natural History and producing video
bulletins and actually really working on
communicating science and it's now
taking his fascination of using images
and data actually moved to Noah where
he's working on the basically how how do
we communicate climate two and climate
change the public submit we're looking
forward to hearing your insights on this
and I'm not going to refute anything
that dr. Schmidt just said I sympathize
completely and I think no one will be
surprised if there are some common
themes I think among the panel but it
should be noted we didn't really
coordinate our messages but we have been
thinking about these things because
we're being barrage in the media and by
society to respond to really the culture
wars that's what this boils down to and
we sort of have two images of scientists
in our culture one is a dedicated
hard-working highly intelligent selfless
individual who stays up late every night
and on works weekends never goes to
movies ultra nerd really focused on
understanding complex things and also
happens to be providing information that
could be useful to us if we were to take
advantage of it and put it in the
context of our decisions that we're
making we have another image though of
scientists that's being actively
promulgated of conniving and clever
people in some geo conspiracy sort of
the scientific mafioso attitude to and
they're hell-bent on misanthropic and
mean-spirited plans to change how we
live and frankly I've never been able to
relate to that second perspective in any
way my mentors in life are dedicated
scientists who much more closely fit
that first category and it really
surprises me that there are people in
society that do hold that second opinion
but thinking it's bad is not going to
make it go away it does exist and it is
a problem we have to deal with in our
society so the I think there is some
work being done to bridge this gap
that's worth pointing out
and it is it comes from the cultural
cognition project at the Yale Law School
this is just one example among dozens
around the world you can find that are
very high quality social science and
sabina is going to talk more about
social science after me and so but I
just want to loo to this one study
because I think it does focus on the
right issue which is how do we frame
discussions so that people can hear what
the science is telling us and in in this
project they're looking at major
societal issues dozens of them one of
them happens to be climate change
science and in in one of their research
projects they took samples of popular of
their population and gave different
samples different messages one was an
article in which they established the
basic record of the surface temperature
record of Earth and show that
anthropogenic warming is happening and
that we could solve this problem through
anti-pollution measures they gave
another subsample of pop the population
the same basic facts and established
that we could use nuclear power to
redress anthropogenic global warming and
what they found is that with random
samples of people that you actually had
more people who self-identify as
individualists and hierarchical
basically beaver cleaver types believing
the facts of global warming when given
the nuclear power option versus if you
told them we need regulation and it
really does come down to values and the
decisions people want to make determine
really influencing the messages they're
willing to hear so we may not like
knowing that but I think it's a tool
that we can use to understand how to
establish dialogue not manipulate people
but establish dialogue around solutions
in ways that people are going to be
comfortable and that's sort of a set of
realizations that I've been working at
weaving into my own efforts and
visualization so I'm going to present
three examples of how i use have been
using visualization over the recent
years and focusing mostly on climate
issues because that's my job now but in
my previous career I was at the American
Museum of Natural History down the
street on right off central park west
and we took scientific data worked very
closely with NASA in fact and Noah to
really give people the details of the
science so in this set of examples i'm
going to talk about communicating the
science and getting to the scientific
principles now necessarily we have to
come up with messages and ways of
communicating scientific concepts that
people can understand because the fact
is we don't have a society of PhDs in
physics we have to communicate with
people if we want them to understand the
science so so we learn things like don't
know what colors me when you look up
data so scientists know what how to read
a color scale and go right in order and
establish that there's relationship
between of colors
and the colors on the hook and then
those main departures of temperature
from average conditions in the ocean so
there's a whole subtext that we don't
have to explain well that went fast
there's a lot of subtext that we don't
have to explain when talking among
scientists that we have to explain when
talking to other people outside of their
discipline now the last frame of that
which didn't stay up sort of showed you
some of the impacts of El Nino around
the world one of which is moister who is
more precipitation in the southern and
eastern United States so we are in an El
Nino now it's weakening but this is one
of the factors that contributed to this
winter's heavy snowfall what happens is
that the warmer ocean temperature in
that region that I was pointing out in
the previous visualization leads to
higher evaporation and that has it is
called a teleconnections where that
moisture is carried in the atmosphere
over into the southern and eastern
United States carrying with it more
moisture that falls as precipitation so
being in an alma no is a factor for what
we experience this winter in terms of
more moisture and the NOAA attribution
team has has been looking at this issue
closely another factor in this winter's
temperature has been the Arctic
Oscillation so here you're looking at a
map which has several things on it the
colors represent deviation of
temperature from average condition this
was observed in early februari this is
februari 12 11 and these are reanalysis
data where the temperature in red are
warmer than average and the blue colors
are cooler than average and what you see
in February was that we had cooler than
average conditions in the central and
eastern United States much warmer than
average conditions in much of the Arctic
that cool temperature also extended into
Europe and northern Asia well it turns
out
that that's pretty much what happens
whenever you have an Arctic Oscillation
in the phase it's in now which is a
negative phase so this is just a
geophysical concept and combined with al
nino you get this pattern so this is 30
years of data represented in one image
showing effectively the same patterns
and this is what we see on our planet
when the conditions we experienced this
year happen it's in our record and we
can document it and show it to you so
that's one way visualization can help
establish a frame of reference to show
what we understand about the climate
system now it turns out that the Arctic
Oscillation and El Nino both factors are
consistent with what we experienced this
winter but what we experienced this
winter isn't consistent with our
projections from from global coupled
ocean-atmosphere models so in this case
we have and by what I'm trying to get at
is that this is not a prediction of
those models that we would experience
this so in this case this is about the
variability of the weather climate
system so separating variability this is
what our attribution team came up with
so we will get back to it we'll get back
to it and in fact we have a record that
establishes the North Atlantic
Oscillation observations which is the
difference in pressure between this
region of the Atlantic and this region
and what we see is that this year we
were in a very negative phase of the
North Atlantic Oscillation which was a
typical in our record and in the last
decade or two decades we've really been
in more of a positive phase overall this
is very washed out but what I was just
showing you is sort of snapshots of
climate-driven weather events from the
went from the winter this is a snapshot
of the close of 21st century climate
under one scenario that couple
ocean-atmosphere models chest if a whole
suite of assumptions are true you can
see you would see if this wasn't washed
out that pretty much the whole planet is
in this warmer than average condition
and we given that you can't really read
the image i think i just want to point
out that there are just two very small
patches in the arctic and antarctic
oceans where we see cooler than average
conditions and thats due to changes in
ocean circulation patterns that are
projected under continued greenhouse gas
warming assuming that we peek at nine
billion and drop off at our missions
drop off as we even as we convert to new
energy technology so we can come back to
modeling I hope we will you can
definitely see more examples of
visualizations of this type through Noah
through NASA through the American Museum
of Natural History I wanted to briefly
also talk about some examples of using
visualization may be focusing on the
cross over to societal issues so in
Copenhagen we had a five-foot diameter
sphere science on a sphere hanging in
the public space that the United States
had for delegates visitors press anyone
walking through the hall and here you
see director of the earth systems
research lab sandy McDonald describing
the same model projections I was just
showing you a still image of we produced
a movie that was in 23 languages that
sort of establish some of the themes of
the conference what climate change is
the challenges it represents and why
it's important that we come up with
solutions obviously I'm glad you
mentioned cop15 it didn't lead to any
substantial agreements but also a cop 15
off-site sort of gorillas style I was
volunteering with 350
org on my own time doing science
outreach helping people who were there
as NGO delegates and student delegates
people who were there really more as
political trying to exert political
pressure giving them some understanding
of the earth system and just leave you
perhaps with some of their thoughts this
dome here rocks you know everybody
should be in it
the visualization you have in the dome
is a good thing because people do not
understand reports and figures so a seed
like you have here have a tremendous
effect on the human mind it was really
good everyone should see this it was
very inspiring come from London just
have a nice lie-down in the ga dome and
treated to some world information that
we all know about but presented in a
really clear way really Interactive's it
away the way which is engaging I just
said it's exactly what we need to create
a paradigm shift in society that we
really need a moment I think last week
hello bigger abandon her unique
it's really brilliant idea to guessing
get perspective kind of overwhelming
experience in that place but it was
brilliant i think is amazing amazing
idea once to my second time i came i was
here for the first time yesterday and I
was far away
it was really powerful reaffirmed hell
in techniques where and now I'm startups
so freaking awesome
the third example I sort of had three
examples one traditional science
directly taking on trying to explain
science people using visualization as a
tool the same way scientists use
visualization to understand their data
represent their data the second example
which I didn't get to show you was how
we were representing earth system
science in a cop 15 in the United States
official presence at cop15 and this
third example speaks more directly to
the effective sort of how people
experience and understand things what
they respond to and we've designed
programming that get that ties together
the cosmic the global and local issues
in an experience that people can really
see the relevance of all these different
scales in one immersive experience and
we're building a network nationally of
people through museums doing this kind
of work because we've realized that it's
really this the experience of seeing
earth systems that's going to it that is
more effective and reaching people and
getting away from these these
diametrically opposed politically
motivated viewpoints we can just focus
on facts by establishing really a new
frame of reference and that's what kind
of keeps me and visualization keeps me
inspired
yes one more thing to say I and and this
is directly because of the nature of the
political atmospheres I am a contractor
for Noah and I don't speak for Noah I do
need to say that when I speak in public
ok now we had the political disclaimer
on up here I thought I had another one
thanks myth well now we've had sort of
from the you know Gavin's experience as
the scientist and a spokesman in the
science community and we had Ned who's
working on how to try to figure out how
to visualize those complex things that
we do you know the pictures that I spent
all my life you know pouring at images
and I say my head's underneath the ice
sheet often it's not really very useful
place to describe what I'm carrying
around in my head doesn't really help
people understand things even though it
might be useful but what we're going to
hear from next is dr. serene marks who
is the associate director for a very
interesting Institute here which is the
Center for Research on environmental
decisions so now we're moving from you
know the you know the true card-carrying
physical scientists actually to what Ned
was alluding to was actually the social
science how people learn how people
understand and how we can better
understand how to communicate on it so
so I will talk a little bit about why
climate change communication is so
difficult or seems to be so difficult
and why has it been somewhat
unsuccessful in motivating people to
change their behavior and it's really
great to see what net has presented that
visualization has come a really long way
from the initial images of climate
change and charts and graphs to
something that's much more animated and
much more engaging that people want to
go back to twice to see it as the one
participant reported so we've learned
quite a bit from the decision sciences
are from cognitive and social psychology
that we can apply to this context of
climate change communication and
research at our Center for Research on
environmental decisions and other places
that study these issues um sure they're
create barriers and limits to our
decision-making processes and I'll share
a subset of topics and problems that we
tackle activate and offer some solutions
as to how to improve climate change
communication and how to eventually
improve our decision making processes
and behavior so I'll start with some of
the main barriers on the first one and
probably most important one is
uncertainty people find uncertainty
uncomfortable we all human humans have a
great need for predictability we want to
know what whether it's like tomorrow we
want to know how things work we want to
have some certainty as to what our life
is going to be like tomorrow and in the
future um so there's uncertainty about
nature and science itself is actually
one effort to reduce uncertainty about
nature so it's it's 11 sign of our human
need for for predictability we created
science the resins about nature there's
this uncertainty about nature there's
also uncertainly about inherent in the
forecasts of forecasts about climate
change predictions for
what climate variability on your lenia
are conditions and these are big as
uncomfortable but then there's also
uncertainty as to the solutions that are
being proposed that would mitigate
climate change there are unintended
consequences associated with greenhouse
gas emission strategies or emission
reduction strategies so uncertainty as
to who will adopt these strategies and
who will not adopt them so there's this
social uncertainty as to when I the only
one am I the the early adopter who will
be isolated or will I regret that I
adopted when no one else adopts and in
those cases coordination is needed and
very badly needed then a second barrier
is some public risk perceptions and
attitudes perceptions matter and stay of
matter more than facts and public
perceptions is what politicians are look
to our they look to their constituencies
and they will not want to implement any
policies that will not be accepted by by
their constituencies so in order for
policies aimed to reduce carbon
emissions on or to reduce our carbon
footprint for them to be implemented
politicians want to know that they fall
on oakley years but climate change is
very often seen as a very distant
problem spatially and your craft
spatially and temporally at this problem
it happens far in the future and it
happens to people in places far away
from us so and that's not the thing that
gets people excited to take action so in
order to get people's attention we
should try to to create something that's
more tangible and if possible show
possible local impacts of off climate
change and one example to do is dislike
to we can refer back to the 2003 power
outage caused by major heat way for
thousands of people have to walk across
the Brooklyn Bridge because the subway
system was shut down
and people suffered a heat heat stroke
and elevators for our people were
complaining of being able to get into
their apartments etc so this is one
example of possible local impacts of
increasing global temperatures in other
ways that gone looking at sea level rise
and how it might affect New York City
and I don't want to say that we have to
localize everything it's just like and
we do not want to distract from global
warming as a global problem that will
affect the entire globe but in order to
get attention we might want to point out
some of the local possible local impacts
another barrier is myopia our cognitive
shortsightedness magnifies the immediate
costs and sacrifices associated with
environmentally responsible behavior for
instance we're much happier on in our
cold or freezing apartment or office we
do not want to reduce the temperature or
increase the temperature in our room now
to suffer just a little bit where let's
like to do that but we don't care about
a possible power outage that will occur
like tomorrow morning or on the
afternoon when we all come home and turn
on our acs so we're very short-sighted
short minded myopic and this with
terrible consequences then cultural
values and political orientation played
she plays a huge role and gavin has
alluded to this the whole climate change
debate has been politicized very
extremely one example of our research
our graduate student David Hardesty has
done a study where he showed that how
important it is how we frame an issue
for instance public support for co2
regulation varies greatly for
Republicans and Democrats when it is
labeled as a carbon tax or carbon offset
so even if people are told that the
that revenue from both of these programs
will be used for the exact same thing
for education investment in renewable
energy etc so more liberal respondents
arm did not discriminate between the two
labels they were equally in support of a
carbon tax or a carbon offset but the
more conservative individuals strongly
preferred the carbon offset to the
carbon tax so just this minor detail in
label triggered positive or negative
responses and republican or self people
who reported themselves as being
oriented or being members of republican
party we're happy to accept a carbon
offset but not a carbon tax then all
peoples golds matter greatly in their
decision-making and self-interest versus
collective interest it's a big issue
when it comes to climate change and in
terms of changing behavior climate
change mitigation is very often
associated with personal sacrifice or
perceived as detrimental to economic
growth so people face a dilemma between
their self-interest and the greater good
for society and the environment in the
long term and I'll go into an example of
how we might be able to overcome our the
self-interest for the sake of collective
interest in just a minute but it's
important to notice that people have
multiple goals and very confident very
often conflicting goals so if we can tap
into people's ability to to motivate
their like collective interest and their
social goals environmentally associated
goals we can be very successful we have
to tap into a variety of goals that
people have and the last barrier that i
will talk to about its communication and
processing of information and a typical
abstract science communication doesn't
seem to motivate people to take action
because most people don't turn these
abstract images
such ass and where did they go no okay I
think those images aren't there i had
the Mona lower curve and climate change
projections up to a year 2100 I thought
I have them on my slide and the people
can't wrap their minds around these
projections it's too abstract people and
people do not allow elaborate on them
not because they are lazy or they don't
have to cognitive capability is humans
trying to do as little as possible when
it comes to processing information also
we have very very selective in the
information that we want to process all
we try to find confirmation for what we
already believe and try to build
information into our existing mental
models of how the world works and if you
believe in climate change you will try
to find information that confirms this
if you don't believe in climate change
you will you will neglect information
and that would they would show you
otherwise so I'll now run quickly
through a couple studies and examples of
how we can improve our communication to
change behavior let me use water
management as an example of an
environmental decision and summer is
coming up in many counties and cities
are starting will start to put up water
conservation messages and people can
either decide that they want to water
their lawn or they can decide to comply
with these with these policies and they
end up either with a beautiful golf
course like lawn or they end up with
this now one one of our graduate
students now postdocs Poonam Aurora had
observed the following in a New York
County when the larger county sent out a
letter to encourage people to preserve
water there was very little response
when the village send out the letter
compliance went up now one explanation
for this is probably the increased
affiliation that people felt with the
village
whereas the county was too big of a unit
to send out this letter so the village
has known others where's the county has
unknown others so based on this
anecdotal evidence poonam Aurora
designed a lab experiment to measure the
effect of social goals and in particular
the level of affiliation the effect that
the level of affiliation has on
cooperation we under study with
four-person groups analogous to four
large greenhouse gas emitters and play
the game where there is a financial
incentive to defect this is a typical
commons dilemma she created four
different levels of proved affiliation
ranging from an anonymous group these
people only knew there are other members
in a group they didn't see these people
they weren't necessarily and they
weren't in the same room the next group
had a shared symbol they knew they are a
member of the yellow star group they
didn't see they are their group members
but their paperwork had a yellow star
marked on the upper right corner then
then was a co-present group where people
sit in the same room together but
they're not allowed to interact but they
do see each other and the fourth level
of affiliation was created by a co
present crew which worked on one
unrelated task prior to playing the game
and in this case we asked students to
come up with a topic that they feel
strongly about that they should write
about to the Dean and the crew had to
write this letter they are like 15 20
minutes the letter was actually
submitted to the Dean and he's probably
still reading all of these and and then
the group plates this comments dilemma
game after they had worked together so
four levels of affiliation and mentioned
these students did not know each other
at all before hands historic students
from from all over campus
so in this experiment we found that as
affiliation increased so did cooperation
affiliation made social goals and
concern for other a creator priority the
added benefit of cooperation made up for
the sacrificed money that people left on
the table so in this case and in game
theoretical terms we can say that a
common dilemma can be transformed by
social goals to a payoff structure with
multiple equilibrium so an experiment
the in this experiments worked even
though students had these temporary
affiliations they didn't know each other
before hand and they were not committed
to doing anything with each other ever
again so the implications of this are
like if we want to promote cooperation
we have to activate social goals in
people and we can do that by integrating
the social anti economic goals and by
emphasizing this umbrella affiliation
are in a parallel affiliation of players
so targeting these social goals and
concern for others will result in very
different decisions then if economic
goals are outputs at the forefront the
second example here's my slide with SIA
one lor curve and the variation in the
earth's temperature over the past 1,000
years information has been presented in
this way does not does not generate a
lot of fear or anxiety about climate
change unless you maybe you're Gavin
Schmidt that you work with this all the
time so unlike the audience here today
who obviously cares about climate change
most people don't seem to have responded
well to this form of information it
requires analytic processing it requires
time experience at a minimum interest
and for a long time people have thought
I'd like the reason why people have not
responded to climate change information
is because there was an information
opposite and we need to provide more
information so that people will find you
take action however um the reason why
this information does not engage people
is people can't relate to it and it's
too abstract it's too distant so to
explain a little bit like how we process
information now humans rely on to
processing systems and they are they
interact they work in parallel they
interact but for clarity say we have
separated them into this rational
analytic system and a more experience
based emotional effective system and the
analytic system analytic logical
deliberative are it encodes reality and
abstract symbols words and numbers rules
and algorithms need to be learned this
is not hardwired and the system needs to
be queued it does not operate
automatically so this system is the one
that needs to be activated in order to
process the typical science ipcc style
on information on the other side the
emotional effective system is based on
experiences that we have it's holistic
intuitive it's effective are risks RC
risks are translated into feelings risks
are represent fear dread anxiety etc and
this system encodes reality in concrete
images and narratives are and it's
linked in our associative networks it
operates automatically it's without
training its response much faster so if
the two systems are in conflict when
making a decision usually the decision
is dominated by the effective emotional
system because it reacts so much faster
this table can easily be also
illustrated with this illustration where
I don't think I need to explain this
similar to what what I would but I'd
like to run a what experience can do for
us when since this is an example of like
someone who has recently experienced a
flood will be much more likely to to be
afraid of the next flood and will
actually be overestimating the risk of
any next flood that's what experience
can do it to us similar to personal
experience our second hand experience
can help people relate and can create an
interconnectedness between us and the
larger world this is a village chief in
an Alaskan village who are in a series
of videos and and documentaries explains
how life and culture has been influenced
by global warming in his village come
now um if this emotional system is so
powerful why are we not using this more
effectively why aren't we why aren't we
changing all of our climate change
information is information we have this
knowledge we know that emotions are a
wellspring for action and why are we not
using it to raise attention to lead to
stronger engagement with an issue and to
motivate action well there are downsides
to overusing the emotional side because
we have only a finite pool of worry and
this is illustrated in this behind this
slide where we might worry about global
warming after attending this lecture but
tomorrow morning if your company or your
spouse's company announces that they are
downsizing you're much more worried
about that even though the state of the
global climate has not changed in the
last 24 hours so we can only worry about
so many bad news at a time and um and in
addition to not being able to worry
about so many things at the same time is
like we can we can we find that there's
a numbing to over use of emotional
yields so people are starting to be very
tired of seeing the polar bear because
they feel like well we've seen is over
and over again it doesn't trigger the
same response any more than when when
the polar bear became the poster child
of climate change in the first place
don't know what is okay here we go what
I would suggest then is a combination of
the emotional and the analytic appeal
and here we have a slide of some 20 time
series of glacial retreat across the
world and for most people this would not
be very interesting I would actually
turn many people off if we want to get
people engaged we should focus in on one
of the time series and pick one point
and see this is what this glacier looked
like at point x at time X then we look
at like there was an 800-meter retreat
in length of this glacier what does that
look like try to show a photo there are
lots of photos available now for a lot
of these glaciers that you can put
together and can show what it actually
looks like when a glacier retreats and
then you can you can go through multiple
of these clashes and try to show that
the information will never be as
comprehensive as the time series but you
have to you have created a way for
people to want to know more what
happened to this glacier you can then
ask an elderly person who has been
around for 80 90 years to explain the
experience with living near this glacier
you can explain the impact of glacier
retreat on agriculture downstream or you
can explain the impact on children's and
on water availability and children's
health in regions that are downstream
from glaciers at that point you may have
people's attention so they actually want
to know why are cleaved palacios rich
reading and you can show co2 emissions
how they have risen and how they will
continue to affect temperature increases
around the globe so this combination
control is one way to get to raise
attention and to get people are much
more engaged now let's assume for a
minute that we have created this great
attention people are willing to change
their behavior and they want
what can we do very often we run then
into this problem that people change the
light bulb which is a great thing it's
very important a lot of people do it but
they stop that's all they do they feel
good about it their sense of
vulnerability the feeling of risk has
been reduced by taking one action and
they don't people don't have the urge to
do anything else this is something
that's a bount across the board we found
this with research with farmers in
Argentina with farmers in Florida who
invest in one form of adaptation to
climate variability and do not follow a
whole portfolio of actions that would be
necessary in order to build a full a
comprehensive strategy to deal with
climate variability similar with climate
change this is also been found actually
in medical decisions where radiologists
who are looking at at images they find
one abnormality and stop looking for
more because they like to have
identified a problem and this is nothing
to do with IQ obviously and it's just a
it's a it's a problem of attention and
and cognition and obviously very serious
so um what can we do about this we can
provide checklists for people that they
can follow so they take more than one
action that doesn't always work if we
know that people only take one action we
should try to promote the most powerful
action order the the action or behavior
that has the greatest potential for
saving energy or for mitigating climate
change if we know that people only do
one thing and that's one of the solution
we could deal with this let me conclude
from what we've learned we can easily
take a pessimist view we constantly make
decisions that are not good for us we
ignore others in our decision making and
we don't choose what would ultimately be
good for us in the long term and forty
environment another problem is that
there's no one size fit
all so how are we going to deal with
this like every different audience needs
a different approach every country needs
a different approach every sector like
the health sector agriculture water
management need different approaches
you're dealing with different
stakeholders so it can be very
frustrating what can we do about that
has a big difference between encouraging
New Yorkers to change to compact
fluorescent light bulbs compared to
reducing deforestation in the Amazon
where we have thousands of stakeholders
in countries that are extremely poor
with the weak institutions but I like to
take the optimist view and I feel that
we can improve the communication of
climate change we there's there's a lot
that we can do and good behavior can be
learned a lot of our studies show that
if we if it motivates the cooperation
and appeal to social goals in people and
appeal to regard for others we can
achieve cooperation and people will
sacrifice some of the economic interests
for a social and environmental interest
and if we involve stakeholders very
early on and through participatory
processes we can help tailor the
information and I think that is a key
that we need to be in tune and in
contact with our audience is very early
answered we find out what do people need
to know so that we can create
information that matters to them that
they can then follow if you want to
learn more about our research and how it
can be applied to climate change
communication we created this guide over
the last three years it's available at
this website I also have several copies
here if you're interested in taking some
with you thank
alrighty thank you I think now we'll
take questions for the panel and you can
start with anybody'd like and can go up
to the microphone please
yes thank you my name is Phil we went on
from Australia if you haven't worked out
already I will start with a rather
depressing observation I've worked on
the government's Victorian Government in
Australia's water plan communications
during a 13 year drought and one of the
things we discovered was that the closer
people were to the epicenter of the
drought the less likely they were to
believe in climate change the closer
they were to the inner city and the in
the labor or I should say a democratic
party voting suburbs the more likely
they were to believe in climate change
in both Australia and the US climate
change has descended into a partisan
battleground despite the hope I think
earlier on that it would be a unifying
issue around which science science and
the broader community could engage
without getting their hands dirty we now
know that's not going to happen so how
do you think we can best most
effectively target that audience who are
get a ball not the people who believe
that Obama is the Antichrist and not the
people that believe already the climate
change is a serious issue that needs
addressing how do we target I didn't
hear anything about targeting today so
that's reported my question relates to
so the study that I referenced out of
the Yale Law School talks specifically
about that and a number of people around
the country are talking about that I
imagine you might be collaborating with
Ed Maybach and Tony laser wits and so
people are talking a lot about how do
you target influential people in the
communities and dr. Marx referred to the
fact that when the village sent out a
message it was more influential than
when the county sent a water
conservation message and that I suspect
has to do with affiliation community
sighs and who you respect so targeting
is about identifying the people who are
respected in different communities and
the issue of whether or not they are
vocally saying Obama is the Antichrist
is a little bit irrelevant if they have
decisions to make about their crops or
their insurance premiums or something
that touches their lives and I think
that what a consensus is emerging or at
least there is an emerging understanding
that rather than talking directly about
climate change and it's always about
climate change you can talk about the
ways that complex environmental systems
and their problems are manifestations of
systemic processes that have other ties
in to people's livelihood and I think
that that is something that is emerging
and growing as an idea and I and I
suspect that you'll see more and more
not NGOs kind of taking that stance but
I can also say that working within NOAA
there's a lot of interests and how do
you work with different communities of
people some of which may not give it may
not care about science per se but the
impacts are important to them
can I um I I think I think the key to
what it is you're talking about is is a
realization why it is what it did why
you're trying to communicate these
people on what it is that you want to
communicate now and I have to kind of
pull on something that you said that
communication was there in order to
change behavior now that is a reason to
communicate but it certainly isn't the
only reason to communicate and I think
if we talk about the goal of
communication merely to change people's
behavior then I think we can quite
rightly be accused of being
propagandists and that is something that
your farmers in the murray-darling
Valley are very sensitive to they don't
like being preached that and you know
they've been living there way for a long
time and they don't take kindly to
people from darlinghurst coming in and
saying hey you guys you know you should
change all your life and we're going to
communicate in order to change your
behavior okay it doesn't matter what it
is that they're trying to communicate
once you start off with that premise
you've lost so the the issue that has to
be kind of considered is ok if you want
policies to be put in place or people to
follow policies you don't have to have
everybody agreed with the reason for
that policy in order to get that policy
that there are lots and lots of overlaps
that I find all the time with people who
are you know they'll they'll swear blind
that Michael Mann is the worst person in
the world but are perfectly happy to
drive around in an electric car right ok
so I don't care what their opinion is
about you know friends of mine but it
matters whether they change their
behavior so looking for overlaps where
they would want to do something that
your people in the inner city also want
to do is much much more important than
getting them to change their mind
about any scientific aspect which quite
frankly you know most people's opinion
about science per se doesn't have much
impact on anything but getting policies
put in place getting people to make
decisions whether they're conscious or
not of why they're making that decision
that's much more important and so
finding overlaps in terms of actions is
much much more important than trying to
get everybody to think the same way i
would say identifying a person of trust
is the other thing is like finding a
context that people really care about
and then linking that up with the
climate change problem people very often
the mean is we care about help their own
health or their children's health and if
we if we can lay out the multiple
impacts of climate change and show the
linkages of health to water to pollution
to climate change people are more open
to to learning more about the general
problem but i think it's identifying the
right frame for people to start to
connect tends to open a path where they
allow new information to come in that
they don't project right out of hand and
it's very on to the work being it feels
like yeah you just want to manipulate
people so everybody comes
there is no way not to frame an issue
it's impossible to have a mutual frame
so why not take advantage of frames that
are to the benefit of people for
instance this has been shown in saving
for retirement no one could say it's bad
to save money you don't want to like so
all your money away were like saving for
retirement in general I seen as a good
thing and by presenting retirement
savings plans in a way that made it
easier for people to sign up we're using
this information from the decision
sciences to help people make better
decisions for themselves and for others
and I think with climate change we can
do it too without manipulating people of
in a way that we want people to behave
hi my name is Renee Cho and I do some
writing about climate change and can you
speak ? a company I'm sorry my name is
Renee Cho and I do some writing about
climate change and I was just noticing I
mean with the weather that we've had
this winter there are so many people who
have actually experienced horrible you
know emotional upheavals and traumas
from the weather and yet I've never
heard anything on the news or in the
paper connect the weather or the extreme
weather to climate change and so if
we're talking about people receiving
risks in terms of emotion and experience
it seems like that would be an ideal way
to sort of make them connect the dots
but it hasn't happened you can you
explain that well the reason why hasn't
happened is because there isn't that
connection we you know you discussed
attribution of particular events over
the winter that never come up with and
and I think you said one thing that was
was very wrong you said that that was
inconsistent with what the climate
models were predicting okay let me just
jump in with that what I was I did miss
phrase it the climate models did not
make that prediction that I did not
intend inconsistent son okay so I'm not
I'm not pointing out to say we said
something wrong but I'm pointing out
just to indicate that even among people
who are working on this all the time the
notion of what climate science is
predicting or projecting into the future
is very poorly understood climate models
are not trying to predict what's going
to happen in the weather next week right
they can't there's a there's a
fundamental limit to our ability to
predict the weather that'sthat's limited
by chaotic dynamics which makes anything
past two weeks an impossibility not it's
hard not that it's going to take us
awhile together an impossibility and so
when we have weather events that come
along we have a big snowstorm we have a
big rainstorm we have some weird pattern
I get a call you know on a very regular
basis from somebody in your post saying
hey is this is this all about climate
change is it now will we see in climate
change and I have to say no this is
whether there is no
who you know nobody has ever claimed the
weather stops because climate change
happens right these are two different
things the climate change is something
that's happening in the statistics it's
happening in the long-term trends and it
will become and in places it already has
become a noticeable thing that people
can you know remember from well you know
how much snow did we have when we were
young you know how many days do we have
over 90 degrees when we were young
compared to how we are now those things
people notice but they're in statistics
the actual weather events however
extreme it is it's a really really
really really really really really
really really hard thing to attribute to
climate change so the reason why you're
not hearing anything on the news with
climate scientists say oh say look
extreme weather it must be climate
change is because that's extremely
irresponsible because when that when you
start to do that um you say oh well it's
really warm this week it must be global
warming well the next time it's really
cold that everybody says hey a loose
ends are still going right and so and
you get just call into a trap short term
behavior is not climate change right
full stop it doesn't matter whether it
supports what I'm saying that's going to
happen in 50 years time or it doesn't
support what I'm saying is going to
happen in 50 years time they're just
different things it's like okay well can
I come up with a metaphor on the fly of
those are just not generally very
successful um but you know that the
models that we have they include with
right they have weather components in
them and if you looked at them the model
you know so I I have a model that I run
that was part of the IPCC reports and
everything and you look at what it does
then there's weather and that there are
winters that are warm there are winters
that are cold there are Arctic
Oscillation that are in a very negative
phase there are articles lations in a
very positive phase over time there's an
increase in the Arctic Oscillation
towards a positive phase which is the
opposite of what we saw this winter but
there is whether there are el ninos that
occur right it's not that what happened
now was unpredicted by climate models
it's that what happened this winter is
not the same as what we're trying to
predict with the climate model we're
trying to predict the long-term trend
and the weather component is is not
something that we can deal with by
always when we can deal with it but it's
not something that the climate models
are telling us about so so when when
there's a there's an apparent conflict
between a weather events and a
projection for 2100 there isn't conflict
because one is a projection for twenty
one hundred ninety years time and the
other one is a weather event that
happened last week these are not the
same things kill who take the next
question I just wanted to point out that
I mean the point of my examples was to
really show that one of the challenges
we have an establishing connection is
with climate information is really
getting people to even appreciate the
spatial and temporal scales on which
climate is even studied and understood
and so that's why we can look at climate
phenomena on a seasonal basis and I
agree wholeheartedly that the
attribution I do with that has to do
with cycles and bigger patterns and we
study those over seasonal or decadal
scales and the point of my showing that
climate projection is that the best way
to interpret those are as multidecadal
summaries that's a an efficient way of
understanding what projections from
models tell us but I agree also that
they don't tell us about whether
establishing an emotional connection
with climate issues can be a useful
thing to do for example in on our site
climate gov we have stories about
effects on biodiversity these are so for
example we have to move loggerhead sea
turtle nests you'll find images of this
on our site because of shoreline erosion
and sea level rise and increase
intensity of storm surge that is
something that to get your mind really
around it you have to think in the big
picture in time and space
and that's where we're striving to get
people to begin thinking in terms of
systems but not I also agree with the
idea not responding with every weather
event and attributing that to climate
change thanks I guess in the interest of
full disclosure it's I'm Jim if staff
you I'm a reporter with Bloomberg News
he it seems pretty clear that the
erosion I guess and the confidence of
the science has affected the debate in
Washington over policies and perhaps
contributed to making it more difficult
for for Congress to act so Gavin I'm
just wondering if among the science
community there's a feeling that you you
need to get out and try to re-establish
improve the credibility of climate
science in some way and if that's the
case how are you doing it and if not is
it just a function of well you know
you're going to sit back and in five or
ten years it's going to be clear that
you're right anyway so why bother um so
I'll I'll challenge one premise of your
question which is that what's happened
over the last three months has changed
the environment in Washington as far as
i can tell nobody has changed their mind
because of any of this the staffers who
are asking us about you know how various
studies fit into the pattern what the
role of black carbon is what the role of
methane is all these things people are
still asking us interesting questions
and they as that hasn't changed over the
last three months a friend of mine just
testified further for the energy and
global warming committee on you know
packages of you know what you would need
to do to have like comprehensive climate
legislation including aerosols including
short term gases
the discussion on the hill about
legislation at the level where the real
details work that has not changed okay
so so I but but but your your finger
point is is I think valid and the
question is well how do you how do you
build trust and how do you let people
see what it is that you're doing the
process the methodology the issue is not
about specific results the issue is not
about trying to prove to somebody that
the that the trend in global mean
temperature has been exactly point eight
degrees centigrade over the last hundred
years the issue is much more about can
you humanize this process who are the
people that are coming up with these
things what are they thinking about how
are they thinking about this is one of
the ways that I've noted that works very
well it is to just humanize the process
who are these scientists who are the
people who are doing this work I'm not
just you know the five people who are
always being quoted in The Washington
Post or the new york times but just you
know the people who are doing the knob
that I mean and not it's not even the
grunt work it's it's the real work um
but who aren't necessarily always in the
spotlight and in fact did quite often
deliberately avoid being a spotlight
where are their voices being heard and
one of the things that I noted I'm so I
did a book that was all about images of
climate change and images of climate
scientists and one of the things that I
noticed when I give talks about that is
that people really respond well to
stories about the scientists doing their
work stories about you know camping out
on the the Arctic ice for nine months or
going down to Antarctica to drill in the
through the ice sheets like Trevor was
doing recently or going to climbing up
mountains to take to try and get samples
of trees that are being uncovered by
melting glaciers or going to the tropics
and finding old corals to get an idea
about what el nino did a hundred years
ago 200 years though people really
identify with the goals of these
scientists you know we're trying to work
out what's going on we're trying to
trying to puzzle our way through and we
only have partial data and uncertain
methods and we're still trying to work
something out people really identify
with that and so I think if we if we
bring up our more of those people and we
say no you know we don't need to just
hear from me or from Steve Schneider or
from Jim Hansen all the time we can talk
to Trevor we can talk to you know other
people like Peter or or Robin or anybody
else just to kind of widen it out just
to make people realize that this is a
much much larger community than they
appreciate that the people involved are
actually just trying to do their best
and work out what's going on in a very
complex system and remarkably are
finding out things about how this system
works that does translate into a better
understanding and I think showing that
process and having people understand the
method and the process is much much more
important than trying to you know defend
any particular result or or or or say
that you know whatever temperature it
was in the medieval period or anything
either so no Sabine do you have
something to say on this you know right
no I've just you know since she's the
social scientist I'd like to know what
she thinks the size 97 can attacked yet
oh no I can only agree with what Gavin
said I I think the idea of having are
you sure who is behind the scientist
it's not just this voice this is a
person or it's like abstract thing as
abstract as it's not scientists say it's
that scientists or her or him
finish let her see the multiplicity of
scientists that they may come showing
that within science there are also
multiple views it's not just as
promising of the second census like
science itself criticizes itself
scientists that's how science works
science criticizes other scientists and
the to show that there's it's not just
this one face is one image of the
scientist I think that's why I like
Gavin's and Joshua volts hook so much
because it really tries to portray the
multiple passes of science and I think
responding to the attacks I think who
would just responds in the same way that
science has been attacked and that might
not be the best way to do it the only
thing I just add is to underscore
something Gavin said earlier which is
that scientists job isn't reporting
science to the public scientists do
science and I think it's our job in this
room to help society understand what
science is about I Taylor determined
space review earlier this year the
administration cancelled the impose
program the National polar-orbiting
environmental sensing satellite and
there the replacement for it is a joint
polar-orbiting science satellite that's
going to be get the military out of it
and is going to be strictly a NASA and
NOAA project and I'm just wondering this
new satellite using all the sum of the
previous technology is this provide an
opportunity to put some instruments on
it the or sensors on it that could
really engage the public because
satellite imagery is of course been used
by both sides of the debate and I'm just
wondering how vital this new forms
satellite state of space-based imagery
could be I'll take that one because my
expertise is actually the poles and I
actually have a one of the real problems
with the polar regions is that the
satellites that have been watching how
it and have been documenting the change
in the polls are going out of commission
currently so we're likely to be blind
for the next couple of years actually
have a team who's up in Greenland right
now in a dc-8 flying the tracks of the
satellite would have now it sounds I'll
get back to your what satellites are
going up but what's remarkable is
actually an opportunity because when we
can get closer to the ice sheets we can
instead of what the satellites do is
they show us how or how fast the ice
sheets are changing but they don't let
us look through them they don't let us
look at the bottom so what this gap in
the satellite coverage is providing us
is a chance to actually go look in more
detail to try and answer the questions
of how and why the ice sheets are
changing to get back past being able to
just saying they're dropping tens of
meters a years at the edge but actually
looking that very difficult place to
image underneath so we can understand
what the physics are so we can feed them
to people like Gavin who make these
large models so the models will be
better so that's one thing is that
there's actually a there is a gap right
now looking at the poles for the most
recent budget that just came out has
several new satellites including the
follow-on for grace so I think it's
actually looking very good a long one
for watching the poles and the question
will be can we get past what Europe
after is some and what Gavin and Sabinus
that is that images are very important
for communicating and how can we get
how can we capture images that will
convey change and I thought that may
come back to actually having people
explain it as much as the data in the
imagery all right I'm can I a little bit
on the things that have come out of
satellite imagery that have a very
strong resonance are the long-term
records now a long term record when
you're talking about satellites
inevitably involves multiple segments
right because they don't last that long
they last at best you know four five six
maybe seven years maybe eight years but
it's a harsh environment and you keep
needing to replace them in order to get
a long transient and one of the big curl
structural problems that we have in the
way science is funded where satellites
are funded is that NASA is much more
fond of doing something new and crazy
and fantastic than it is in maintaining
long-term operational measurements of
various things which they think are well
that's just nose job um and Noah doesn't
like to be seen just as like being you
know the the just kind of the
hand-me-down satellite operator after
NASA has finished playing with its toys
and so there's a bit of a
miscommunication that happens that I
work for NASA so I I know something
about this the things that have worked
really well with satellite imagery for
instance the trends in sea ice in the
Arctic over since 1979 those have been
very clear they've been very powerful
the collapsing I shells in the Antarctic
Peninsula which were captured by by
visual imagery very very clearly dearly
but it's interesting because those
primarily capture something that's not
directly regulated it's an image not a
direct piece of data that's a bit of a
cool distinction images data its numbers
and then Ace was flooding already well
not stealing the fact that the ice was
floating but there was a big change that
actually have been there for 10,000
years and it disappeared in three weeks
right I think that's something that
people
it's a strong communication right so
that's what we're talking right then I'm
just reminding his communication not the
same as David no there was lots of data
that how does how does something like
that happen right there's there's
information in the images about the melt
ponds that arose about how the cracks
propagate is one of those things are
interesting information to people
looking at I shoulders so okay um next
my name is Richard Morgan I've assisted
dr. James Hansen and with research in
his last who reports to Congress and
also his reason autobiography storms of
our grandchildren and one thing that's
been conspicuously absent because it's
one of the things that's I've had great
interest in lately is that the fact that
the energy industry has put tens of
millions and in fact hundreds of
millions into what a desk at least can
be described as propaganda I think it
were scanned and more accurately be
described as lies to the American people
and to the people of the world about
global warming and all its scientific
aspects we've been through that for
instance and i stopped counting at a
half a billion on clean coal at a point
when there was one clean coal facility
in the world in germany finally the
accident in tennessee cleared that
nonsense up and also above and beyond
that kind of money by the industry to i
feel liab out climate change there's
we've been through a eight-year period
of the marriage of the energy industry
with government and in NASA NOAA there's
been suppression of the true
editing a document us get to the quail
chase the question is until the money is
taken out of in its influence both in
the government and in the media do you
think we can arrive at the truth about
and the American people can can arrive
at it at the truth about global warming
Josephine you want to take that one I
would like to take all the CEOs off like
the big energy sector and put them in a
room and run our experiment with them
and try to motivate their social goals
and I think in each of them there is
also a father or a person who goes who
attends a religious group who cares for
others if we can tap into those parts in
the people who make decisions and people
who Lobby and two people who control the
money that would be great we are I have
not found access to them but I think
there I don't think it's completely
hopeless I think if we have to find a
way to reach people so that they see the
downside of the self-interest short-term
self-interest and again I think it's a
very difficult group to reach and but if
we can if you can't reach them if we can
reach enough others who will then put
pressure on their leaders that that
might be a way a way to do it but I
think it's a really big obstacle I it's
that's not an easy solution
I've endorsed that idea i mean i've been
thinking about that too a way to get
these folks in a room and an experience
and give them this shifted perspective
that immersive visualization but also
carefully crafted narrative can really
facilitate people having these shifts
and realizing that it is one earth
system regardless of your short-term
profit motives we are all connected in
the decisions that you're making and I
think that there is power through these
social motivations that dr. Marx
described can we get the truth out I
think it that's happening I think that
the science of I think that the science
of climate change science is being given
to the public remarkably freely and and
we owe a debt of thanks to our socket
versus some scientists for continuing
that work and it's up to us to read it
and take note really good time for
another question yeah hi my name is
Jessica Rosen and I'm a master student
in the climate and society program here
one of the main goals of which is
communicating climate science so I'm
always interested in these discussions
and I have to run off to class in a
couple minutes but to being you um
talked about the barriers to this issue
one of which the first one being
uncertainty never really hard time
buying that one or just understanding it
because we make decisions based on
uncertainty all the time in our
investments and when we purchase
insurance and when I have devoted my
life to this program when that there is
no job market yet for it so why for this
issue is the uncertainty such a problem
yes very good question i think it's
something a question that we have tried
to to tackle trying to figure out what
is so different about environmental
decision
and uncertainty about climate change and
what is it it is an unprecedented
problem we don't have a lot of analogies
that we can refer to where we find
examples of how we have decided before
it's also much more clothe problem than
the decision like you know should I
enroll in a program that would cost me
hundred thousand dollars I have a job
afterwards that decision doesn't affect
it affects you and your family and your
surroundings but it doesn't have any
effect on the globe at large so that's
that's a difference it's also different
from some of the health related
decisions which also most of them affect
us personally and our families and not
necessarily our health decisions don't
have an effect on on the clove so that
makes it makes it a little more
difficult i think it's the scale and the
scope of it but even in the decisions
that we make daily we go back and forth
on our decisions we deliberate we weigh
the pros and cons you didn't just like
out of a gut feeling apply for korea for
this program at columbia university so
you discussed with others so those
positions are they aren't as easy as we
sometimes think they are and i think if
we can if we can tell people like we
make decisions under uncertainty and we
have ways to make them like choosing a
surgery versus some other treatment to
treat
zzz we do weigh the options and we come
to conclusions and if we can teach
people that Oh climate change
uncertainty it might be created
uncertainty but there is a way to tackle
the uncertainty and that we can make
decisions and the option to the solution
is not to make no decision so I think we
can we can build on some of that like we
have experience with uncertainty but
climate change has different components
and it is a different scale so I don't
think it can we can just simply
translate decision making under
uncertainty from a financial health
context to to the climate change context
I agree with you I think that this
specialization of uncertainty is much
more of a debating tactic than it is a
fundamental barrier to actually doing
anything the stimulus package which was
a trillion dollars worth of stuff was
not done in the certainty that that was
going to fix the problem much much more
investments in in renewables in carbon
pricing or whatever they're not going to
they're much smaller than that and the
uncertainty is actually much less so it
kind of i think i think the uncertainty
discussion resonates partially because
people have a very not in this room of
course but but outside people have a
very skewed idea about what scientists
do right the public perception that
scientists are the people with the
answers and that they pop up at the end
of the movie to say oh what obviously
that wasn't meant to work you know or
you know we wander around in lab coats
give people instant DNA analyses and
tell people but there's obviously that
person there that isn't what we do
science is fundamentally about
uncertainty quantifying it reducing it
but it's never making it go away
everything that we do in science is
always about uncertainty you know even
general relativity is not certain
that's a pretty good you know even
quantum electro chromodynamics is not
certain it's very good but it's still
not a hundred percent right nothing is
every one hundred percent and so I think
it's much more important that when these
kinds of issues come up and so it's all
we're so uncertain that we just try and
break the link that people have between
science and certainty which I think kind
of just can't bubble was under a lot of
people with subconscious and and that's
what you break and then it doesn't
become an issue it then it's well how do
we act in the face of uncertainty and
and I think that what you were
discussing there is really trying to
move that forward okay our last question
well just one small addition to that is
that I don't I just think that the
reason uncertainty sticks is that it
gets a people's sense of security and
insecurity about what they have and
don't have and it's not about science at
all it's an emotional response so yeah I
could go on but questions I'm Hannah
chayim from the center for climate
change law at the law school here um you
find that when you talk to other lawyers
or other policymakers you do end up
getting pigeon-holed into talking about
the science because if you're debating
about you know whether there should be
any climate regulation you know anyone
who can see the analogy you made to the
building anyone who can see the whole
building no one's going to argue that
nothing should be done if you're arguing
at that level the issue is whether or
not you believe climate change is
happening so you you talk about policy
issues but then you start arguing about
the science so I'm wondering if you guys
have sort of thoughts about how when
that happens and you're facing another
lawyer and you're arguing about little
tidbits of science you don't really know
anything about you know genuine
genuinely grasp how do you deal with
that how do you get out of that argument
do you argue on that level or do you
know change tracks how what use is
having that discussion with another
lawyer or another public doesn't know it
I recommend having as little to do with
lawyers as possible but all due respect
any good lawyers who are in the room
which I'll show you okay but I've been
spending way too much time talking to
lawyers in the last few months that I
come the issue is high you know if
somebody if you're talking about
something and then somebody brings up
nuclear fission and you know nothing
about nuclear fission do you start
arguing on the basis of your
understanding about what an atom is no
right don't argue about things that
you're not comfortable arguing about if
people if people want to insist on d
raylene an argument by talking about
15th century true rings or the process
of attribution you have to say look this
is not my thing I rely on the people who
are doing that kind of stuff it's in the
IPCC report take it up with them you're
not an ambassador for the science and
you know you shouldn't feel the need to
be I mean now you should you should read
as much of this stuff and try and
understand as much as tough as you want
you can ask me questions you can email
people that you know with question that
comes up somebody really wants to know
an answer to well what about this what
about that what about that so we know
what I'm gonna work in a big institution
where there are people who are absolute
experts on this world class status i'm
going to ask them and i'm going to get
back to you you're not responsible for
everything that's in the opportu see
report and you don't have to defend
everything that's in the IPCC report if
you want to talk about policy options
talk about policy options don't get
derailed into technical issues that
nothing nothing is going to be settled
by you having that argument I usually
when I get in these conversations like
direct people to a real climate thought
all
but we're part of the conspiracy and
another thing that you can you can ask
of someone who argues that strongly ask
them with oh what what my arm why do
they feel so strongly about the argument
why why why do they feel so emotional
about it and to find out what's driving
them and like to get like what are they
afraid of like an athletic just for a
second you know to take the opposite
position and put themselves in in your
shoes or in in the opposite try to
imagine the opposite opinion and just to
to shake them out of that because they
simply stuck and not open to getting
other information and I'm very often you
can then find that people are there just
like its peers of someone taking away
their lifestyle from them and and and
not wanting to see another side that
that so I think displaying a little role
of game with someone's like well just
for a second we're smart people how
about you take the opposite view and and
see how you would argue in that case can
help people just like to be thrown out
of there where every day is stuck in
being open to new information they can
still go back and argue their way but I
think just to to open up their minds for
just like a brief moment and so they can
them selves understand what is going on
and why they are arguing a certain way
so my father is a lawyer and his his
class as a discussion list an email list
and I guess he's nearing retirement it
feels like he has time for engaging in
some of these kinds of discussions with
other highly intelligent people some of
whom advocate positions from from
positions of relative well lack of
expertise and I've given him coaching on
some of the facts and but I have found
that his style of phrasing an argument
far exceeds my own and I suspect that we
could learn a lot from lawyers about
how to engage in dialectic in a way
that's constructive that is respectful
and that doesn't open up the pitfalls of
trying to engage in the minutiae of
something that we're not all experts in
so I would be interested to hear what a
room full of lawyers answer to that
question let me let me add one little
postscript to to what Sabine said one
question that's I i often find the
answer to very interesting is when
something's arguing with you you say
well where are you getting your
information who sources do you trust and
why is it that you think that a blog
somewhere on Anna somewhere on the
internet is more reliable than the
assessment of the National collision
report and and trying to work out where
people get their information from is is
actually very closely tied to helping
deal with you know possibly full sources
of information that they may have read
somewhere so that's the big tip ready so
I think there are no more questions I
think thank everybody for oh you won
okay good yeah I'm Marcia Montero and
I'm a thousand percent average so my my
my point about this the whole event that
is communicating about climate change
two people together in general I think
that you have to do what everybody does
higher PR put them in the name the tiger
woods the circle if you want to really
reach people you have to do what other
people do he says all the time we are
scientists is not our job there's people
that have the job to communicate things
to other people so use them it's a job
market out there that's it
I think you want to response that oh
well I think that what our Center is not
a marketing center and if we are firm we
are doing research that helps us to
identify ways that will make people
respond in a way that people are
advertising and commercial works for
people and um but when scientists start
to use those tools it's being seen as
manipulation and people don't realize
that every day everything that they see
is being brought to them in a way that
is trying trying to manipulate them to
sell them something and but when science
does it it's seen as its its objective
and and science doesn't want to engage
in using these tools so i think doing it
in more in more subtle ways might be
might be more effective also in getting
like scientists excited about
communicating science i think sign it's
only in the last over the last few years
that scientists have stepped out and i
want to communicate in different ways
other than just in peer-reviewed
journals and it's very new to scientist
scientists are not used to that at being
in a spotlight and and most of most of
us don't don't like it that much that's
why we're in science I guess but I think
a combination of that and yeah using the
tools in a way that people feel
comfortable with would be a very good
thing to do but I don't think that we
can hand on our communication over to
Madison Avenue is actually they come to
us and want to know about our research
because they feel like we know more
about it today
Ned why don't you work yeah I want to
say something cuz you work for the part
of the gun government is trying to
explain climate I think right yes right
we are forming something called the NOAA
climate service it's a proposal right
now to Congress to sort of establish
something analogous to the National
Weather Service around climate but
speaking directly to your point about PR
and movies and popular culture I mean I
do think you see some messaging out
there right now that is focused on
climate change science and policy and
adaptation and the choices we can make
in society that are not driven by
scientists they are driven by people who
have a corporate interest in making
money off wind power for example so
those messages are and will get out
there well I see them on when I am on
the internet particular well well well
that matters a lot and so because i work
for a science agency it's very important
for us to have a communications strategy
that is transparent and that serves oil
and gas and wind and agriculture and
education in every sector of society in
a way that's transparent and egalitarian
because it's taxpayer dollars paying for
the information to be distributed what
I'm trying to suggest in the first part
of my answer though is that there are
commercial interests that will spin up
PR around climate issues but that is
different from communicating the science
and so those people are clients and
consumers of the information just as all
those other sectors I described and
hopefully we can serve all of them with
the information that we can collate
together about climate science and I
think though that this gets back a
little bit to Jim's question about what
are we doing differently I think we do
recognize
that communication requires a set of
skills and expertise that is distinct
from doing the science and so building
that capability and I am intentionally
distinguishing that from PR I just think
that actually translating science into
useable nuggets of information for
different populations is a skill and one
that is going to require professional
development and career building for this
generation but I see that as distinct
from PR and I don't have a problem with
people using PR for PR but I recognize
it for what it is and I think building a
capability around communication is very
important because of all the myth the
tendency in a politicized environment to
appropriate information or quoted out of
context or put it in the wrong context
intentionally and then call that
scientific communication that is not
scientific communication that's
manipulation so I've given you an
unsatisfactory answer you want to see a
clear PR action but that has to come
from society that can't come from the
government telling society what to do I
mean that's not how our governments
supposed to work that's my take on that
okay well thank you all for coming I
hope you've all learned something
you